foreign
what did you tell him nothing
I swears
the Lord sent me his
overseas matters in person
the creature bring it back
kill it
hey there and Welcome to our first
gameplay showcase for the Lord of the
Rings Golem today we will unveil when
the Lord of the Rings Golem will be
released and show a lot of gameplay
directly captured from the game of
itself my name is beyond and I am part
of the delay crew that shows you around
the game and give you some background
story
of today's footage before we go into the
game let me tell you a little bit about
the Lord of the Rings Golem the game you
will see today is in beta so you can
expect some more publishing in the
future builds especially around movement
camera controls and graphics
and I want to start with a little more
background for you regarding our main
character
column is a long-lived creature that
knows Middle Earth like no other he is
very agile and strong so vertical T
parkour and secrecy play a role but we
are concentrating on the story the lore
and especially exploration of parts of
Middle Earth that you have been that
have been hidden to you so far so the
Lord of the Rings Golem is in that sense
an action adventure important for us is
that we took every effort to be close to
the law with alt without altering it we
took our freedom where we tell untold
stories but never change anything about
the existing story
the beauty about Golem story is that we
can make use of his two personalities
leading to moral choices and also
connect the dots between the main
storyline
showing you what happens in Mordor and
other places while they prepare for war
we took great care to show the world how
Golem perceives it be it characters
enemies beasts or landscape the game
plays roughly between Gollum leaving the
Misty Mountains and ends somewhere
around the fellowship entering maurya
be true but that's already enough talk
talk please look for yourselves we hope
you enjoy your trip to Middle Earth and
thank you for your thoughts your bows
and your access
and um so I have with me today damiri
um which is the co-author of The Lord of
the Rings Golem and um so uh welcome to
Miri nice to have you here thanks for
joining us in this pre-recorded session
today and
um yeah please introduce yourself and
say a few words about how a typical day
of a co-author would look like
hi I'm damiri I work in the narrative
Department
um we uh of course we have to think
about the narrative but the story we
developed the characters the side
characters the quests we think about
um what kind of materials they use in
baradoo and what kinds of materials are
not used a typical day is a question
starting with the question and I have to
do a lot of research
and then usually it has to do with art
departments or game design
um yeah that that's it that's usually
what I do
um
um there are some tricky bits uh where
we have to
um think like what would the professor
do because he didn't write about it or
he just gave gave us some hints uh but
uh yeah like uh you you already said
burnt uh there there's a lot that we can
rely on and there's a lot of lore
actually that is already present
awesome yeah and uh with that
um we can go into the footage itself so
it's the first time ever
um some gameplay
um directly captured from the game is
shown so
um I hope you guys enjoy it and um we
will make a few remarks and comments
about this very shortly so
um please sit back and enjoy while we
start starting the footage now
without me
Isa marbles no Darkness they see
faces look gobbled no flurry they feel
yes put some good fish huh
column is one of his hideouts
um you can see not only fish but also
strange things that he collected and we
start with a riddle
me as you all know Gollum loves riddles
and he's particularly fond of one
that has to do with his story
[Music]
inch of space here we are
the place
or a different perspective
yes we had to choose a little different
design because this is uh
based on the books so as you already
said that the design is also based on
the law and of course it's columns
perspective things God perceives people
different than differently than other
people
he perceives the elves as cruel and
flashing eyes he
he perceives murder the place where we
know he went to
that is the tutorial Now isn't it yes
it's a territorial
um besides learning our skills and
introducing the player to uh to the
basic gameplay we also get the first
glimpses of
uh dangerous and dark place
um
as you know Sauron called all the foul
beings a certain stage tomorrow and he
revealed himself and
Gollum searching for the ring suddenly
changed his
Direction and
went also South here we can see Gollum
climbing
it's very strong
yeah he's like really good climber and I
love the view there you know these
little Huts there from the Orcs I guess
so yes yes that's on our camp we know
that the the
mountains surrounding motor uh
protected that there are some guards
there are not a lot of ways you can
enter or you can
you can actually
go along I hear birds animals play a
very important role in tokens writing
and whatever is Golem doing there you'll
find out later
also the footage is is not consecutive
so there are Cuts in between the footage
so if there's like um yes other stuff
coming uh that's always like um a new
part of the gameplay to show it's more
like a teaser footage
it's a it's a bit you can see column
sort of hunting for it is also
mesmerized by it it has this as you said
there's two parts of him the one that's
still reconnects to to Nature we know
that once he left the Misty Mountains
he uh he also got stronger and so to say
back to life
um and you can actually choose how he
behaves which side of him gets the
stronger
development and that's quite important
for the story
you literally decide who's gonna live
and who's gonna die and it's also gonna
bring you into troubles yeah and that's
one of the
um Parts where Golem needs to be very uh
stealthily yes not get caught fans will
maybe recognize a little bit of this
part not this part exactly but later on
you all have heard of the series The
spider cleft and yes
you have to be careful you have to sneak
around you can sometimes also fight
opponents but they as we know from the
Misty Mountain sea sometimes throttled
an orc but small ones and not not
um heavy soldiers stuff like that
yeah yeah you get a little bit
impression of the
Style
that we chose to represent a mother of
course it's
cruel and there are a lot of edges I
really love it yeah I also love it we
have a very very good artist a good art
Department
the hell of a work
um yeah
some spider webs yeah I wonder what
these webs are I wonder where these webs
come from
who is doing this kind of oh another Arc
Patrol yeah that's a patrol we We are
following them because
we are afraid that they might reveal
something
a Golem is uh constantly so to say on
the run and nobody really loves him he
needs to love himself but he also the
smigan side tries to find friends and he
finds friends depending on your choices
good and strong friends to help him out
because he can't he can never do it
alone he's too small but just as a Bilbo
in The Hobbit Frodo in a Lord of the
Rings he's a small creature
ancestor of the hobbits and and that's
good because he can hide like here he
can sneak around nobody is really
interested in him and that gives us the
possibility to show things and Gollum
can enter almost every place I mean he's
he's one of those creatures that saw the
dark lord and still lives yeah so what's
happening now so he's like making it
dark for the orc so he can't see and
then yes yes that that that's a trick uh
he can throw things he can
um so you can you can climb he can even
swim he's a good water man and we just
knocked out a candle or knocked out some
light oops who's that yeah who might
that be
yes we know of his fascination with oh
another famous character right there yes
uh actually a pretty uh
if you think about it uh these fellow
beasts which were mentioned in a lot of
the Rings uh must have grown before Zora
must have raised them we decided to show
them inside of motor
yeah but not outside because he's he's
sort of he's keeping them back for his
War but Gollum being there yeah he makes
another
bad experience
yeah get it captured again yes yes so
you you we already know he will enter
and
yeah yeah too sad
that's yeah there's a sort of frame
story a lot a lot of a little story to
to when Gandalf actually questions him
we know that from The Lord of the Rings
that he actually did he mentions to
Frodo
and um
and he also mentioned that it was very
difficult to get anything out of column
so that gives us some freedom to
interpret this yeah
all do all these little nuances
yeah and now since you were talking
about
um you know
um you know looking for stuff
um so this is inside
um model right this is inside baratua
even
um as you can see Gotham now
um it's not hunted anymore he's a
prisoner
um
but being very clever and slimy and
uh knowledgeable he also knows how to
manipulate people and he very soon gets
the hang of it again depending on how
you play him
and we get to see one of the more like
Central
rooms and Chambers of the more powerful
people yes um
yes
um
then download so it's it's um it looks
like I love how you made barodua
um rather cultivated it's quite a huge
place and you must also uh think or you
might have to realize that Sauron cannot
just like do it all alone here of course
yeah
Clockwork to do his orders and cultists
and people who really yeah that's a very
interesting picture I love that
if you understand what this is about
yeah it has something to do with one of
the central characters in Barak Duo
which is a sort of spymaster
um of course Sora needs to gather
information we know that he has some
birds on his side and
yes and um
and one of these spy Masters called the
candle man for
reasons you can imagine or you can think
of yourself of course he's torturing
people and he's trying to
uh yeah the candle to bring some light
into the situation yes yes it's a very
dark part of Sauron Soren also has a
light uh like he's also talking about
light the you know maybe from uh from
Moria this is
and we know that morgoth also looked for
light and has a sort of his own
life but it's not a very nice light it's
more like a very I like I like the map I
I think I remember well yeah this is
yeah Golem sometimes gets these little
glimpses of what people do and yeah
inserted the map here in the big map
room yeah uh because we thought you know
from time to time maybe the Spy Master
also wants to have a look at where the
troops where you have to stand I love
this war room look it has yeah yeah so I
like that and um the um we just missed
the
um this nice artwork of paratur the
Tower with the eye so
um yeah there's there's like lots of
stuff in in the game like like that so
um of course we had to make some
compromises sometimes you just saw these
these vertical lines white vertical
lines they are usually a little bit a
hint for the player where he can climb
where we're inserted a few we worked
with the lighting and so on to to help
the player looking for the right places
and
has a special scale that's we call this
a Golem sense so if you can activate
that you can also it helps you finding
your way around yeah cool yeah and these
dark Corners again it's not like final
final quality but you know you can hide
ah okay that's another another jump to
another scene uh
column actually gets to hatch his own
little bird
and it's very nice
again although he's in paratur and he
needs his column side smeagle also is
important and in creating on hatching
and protecting this little being this
side of him actually is reactivated
and this bird plays a very important
role so again it's important how you
actually deal with it and um yeah here
we can see the Spy Master the candle man
talking about his past
of course he's as we know that many men
also joined and the dark lord even some
of the
numenores and uh
yeah so he is sort of thinking about his
past his people away yeah it's amazing I
love them
you you get to know a lot and you can
again
use that for your advantage if you're
clever
interesting
the candleman also has a daughter I
don't know whether we'll see it
let's see I I don't know whether she
comes in here but she's uh she's a very
strong believer yes yes I love you will
shoot
you probably know this this King yeah
and that's a famous story
um about the the kings of Gondor and yes
yes
no this place on his past and
and his problems see he's not he's not
such a strong believer as his daughter
but again Gollum can
use that yeah it's it's great that it's
not very clever simple characters all
the way you don't yeah you don't have to
be a hardcore fan to play this to know
this it will be all explained and and in
half yeah but now to some more uh uh
nicer Realms yes that's a another
central part of gollum's Journey Golem's
Quest
um
the halls of of the Alvin King The Elven
Kingdom we call it
um in marquard
we know that they should have
kept him
and when we know the story yeah from the
country we show how it's happening yes
we know from the Council of Aaron that
that he actually uh entered uh that that
that they actually watched him
and that he sort of escaped um
and but we made a quiet interesting
story out of it it's just not not all to
it
because of course you also wonder how on
Earth
did he manage
and you can already see that the elves
after some time in the beginning they
are quite hostile and sometimes also
just talking yeah yes again like only
enemies against them right yes yes and
uh but after a while they try to yeah to
make him more comfortable and leave him
a bit more space
and Gollum of course yeah
we can also collect food because we need
something especially fish
we can get hurt we can also die in the
game so then we have some some some
spots where you can go back to some
saving saving spots
yeah be careful of those lamps that's
not such a good idea yeah I was lucky
and the elves have the other way so
um when I played it it's like okay just
hit him there and you know like find my
way around it so yeah you could have hit
this this this uh this container there
yeah yeah yeah that was so so but it
works that way too so yes there are many
ways you can uh also uh sneak you can
hide you can climb you can you can
choose your ways
um you should also listen carefully to
what people say so if you hide it behind
those boxes and just especially here I
like how she's like um you know
preparations for the party and for the
great feast and so so there I try to
like maybe hit her too and but then I
can write a limits let's be a little bit
more bold you you saw this shadowy bit
that that's that's a place where you can
hide very well yeah yeah so I I got her
attention there but I was quick enough
to to go away and uh yeah I was lucky
there as well so no yeah actually you
can't really uh kill elves because they
they they very soon spot you so you have
to be yeah more careful especially if
you're doing things you're not supposed
to do like now now
so yeah we'll a little bit further in
the level you know like um you have
several possibilities there like go more
the stealth route or there's another
route um where you can do more parkour
like wall runs and stuff like that so
um but here I chose to go
um rather stealthy way a little bit like
um going around or waiting till they
look the other way
yes um they are uh there are some guards
here they um they actually are not
necessarily looking for Gollum
um but as you know the the uh everything
has a very well-defended
Castle or caves realm and voice people
and of course he has very capable
soldiers and Fighters
um but as uh the elves love it they
usually prepare a feast
whatever so they're not that as you can
see there also not that
attentive yeah dangerous yeah so taking
care of Golem so this is now like a part
where there's a little bit more jumping
like for a short time now
yeah more like a pakura area
um we can see a really Steep and like
deep blue yeah Gollum of course tries to
find a way out is not so easy as you
thought yeah um and you have this is
quite far in the game so you you already
know how to do all those climbing yeah
this is the um Elven Palace the um
thronderos Palace from outside yeah
yes very nice design
of course it's good
quite big
um yeah so again Golem is very strong
very tough it tries to get past it
um
yes and it's very beautiful also
sometimes you get these spots where you
can uh look far out into the
surrounding we can see famous and sites
of Middle Earth of course in our
interpretation
um but uh
yeah from time to time we get also these
high spots where we can of course um if
we're doing the cool thing we need that
to especially if you have some enemies
around to know where we should be going
and all of a sudden up there is a fish
and he gets caught okay okay
yes
um really has a hard time you as a
player have to think uh quite fast but
but you get hints yeah yeah you got
caught again I mean it's absolutely just
bring you straight back yeah exactly
so
um yeah I love what's um happening here
um because we um meet someone from
before yes as I already said this is the
bird Crown as you can see
of course Soren uses dark magic and
terrible practices to make things to
grow faster and stuff like that
but that particular bird
yeah it's quite useful okay and you can
like breed different ones so that was
the footage so far
um and
um yeah um I hope you guys liked it a
lot so um but we are not done yet
um we have of course a few questions we
know
um most of you
um uh people want to ask so
um we um go about that so
um
tamiri um one question which is like
kind of the elephant um in the room
um what do you think um or what do you
think um um why did you guys choose to
tell the story of of Gollum
um yes
um I said before that like uh like Bilbo
in The Hobbit
um or Frodo in a lot of drinks Gollum is
not the kind of superhero he's not a
wizard or a sword wielding uh Dunedin
he's small it's clever and just like we
experienced the story from the point of
view of an ordinary person in Bilbo and
later with his nephew Frodo who's
already knows a little bit about abs and
so on from his uncle with Gollum we have
the same possibility
um we have a person that's quite tough
strong of course it's a torn soul but he
has the the possibility to experience
this world of riddles and magic and
wonder and we as a player as well so we
we get this kind of perspective which
was quite useful in the beginning we
also thought like okay is Gollum a good
choice let's see he has also a lot of
skills like Aragon says good Woodsman
good watermen and that's actually very
helpful in the game
um as you could see it's a sort of epic
adventure game with stealth elements so
it enabled us to tell the story from the
perspective of a person who doesn't
really know everything about Middle
Earth and also also too because he he
traveled places everywhere he can he can
enter mode or I mean with an Health
barrier yeah good luck
um so yeah he he he can go to places we
can show a lot and also the time frame
is quite good because after leaving the
the Misty Mountains until he
uh follows the company in in Moria it
leaves us roughly 70 years and what has
gonna been doing all this time and and
of course we know from Gandalf and also
by column himself later on when he
travels with salmon Frodo we know
yeah but some of Gandalf's assumptions I
guess is and of course Tolkien also
writes in his letters and other books
about him but um yeah we had some some
leeway here and we connected that with a
story that um that Tolkien wrote in a
lot of the Rings and with uh Golem as uh
with gollum's story
yeah but that's that's cool so
um we are like um Golem is is usually
um a rather
um
a rather mean
um character at some point at least
sometimes you you think
um he's just a very mean person but you
know is is it really like that what what
do you think about
um um Gollum being a nasty creature yes
of course some of the fans were not so
pleased and said why why you take this
creature
um and as Sam said he is a slinker or a
stinker so that's a hard hard start but
actually uh Golem also has a heart and
he has his own backstory and after a
while we found out that this this um
um yeah we made him also a bit cute
cuter so as you might have noticed
because you have to look at him all the
time but after a while we can see that
that's actually an advantage and we
could we can also take this um
this smeagle and Gollum sides of him
there's a these two personalities that
one that's tortured by the ring but
strong and tough and the other one that
wants to have friends and actually
remembers his past life you could use
that to tell a very good story and as
you know talking himself one of his all
first recordings of the earlier
recordings at the BBC he actually read
the passage with people and and Gollum
so it's quite an important character and
also for other reasons
um he's not that nasty and he's not that
evil
um
um and he's definitely against Sauron so
yeah which is
um it sort of makes him maybe not a real
big hero but who is yeah indeed so I so
it's not always like the big heroes that
make make for the best stories in in my
mind
um but more like
um coming to another topic we we shortly
already touched upon and then that is
where the game
is is happening in in the whole
storyline of the Lord of the Rings and
and the world of Middle Earth so
um how does the Lord of the Rings Golem
fit into the story of the books maybe
you can shed some light on that yeah
please I already said something about
that it fits very nicely
um just between the spaces
um we have
um we have the the the license for the
book so we have to stick to the Lord of
the Rings the story of the book
um but our story also takes part in
places that
um
we know uh like already from The Hobbit
like the merkwood
um the realm of the elves it also takes
place in par in parts that has have
never been visited because as I said
before if you if you would be a dunadan
and be caught in Mordor probably be dead
but um Gollum makes it and we can show
places that he and he saw and now the
player gets to see them and
um
yes also the world Middle Earth itself
is sort of very important uh asset of
the game so we also see Middle Earth in
a version that Gollum perceives it and
this world and then the whole
legendarium behind it plays a major role
in this story as well as Gollum himself
cool but is there
um um so coming more to the game itself
um
um is the game related to other Lord of
the Rings games or is it a standalone
title
no uh
not so far that I know there's I think
no relation
um of course there are parts of the game
or parts of the story because of of
course we all base our stories even the
movies of Peter Jackson they are based
on the books so yes you will uh maybe
no other interpretations for example of
sheilob
um which I personally don't like so much
but our interpretation you are a secret
you are a spy Master yourself you're a
very secret person yeah um when it comes
to infos about the game so um but but
okay okay um that's no reason to play it
and not it's good to not have Yeah in
our game the interpretation of course is
very closely to tolkien's ideas and and
visions of her yeah and as you know
she's a spawn of uh the big evil spiders
that that uh yeah
that come in other Tales yeah okay
um one last big so so two questions left
and the the one last more forget one
question more about gameplay and the
last question we will finally answer
um when the game will be coming out so
um so but first of all
um um so we have seen like two that
Golem do all these tricks with the Elven
guards and throwing rocks and um can you
tell us a little bit about what other
tricks Golem has in store to survive in
his this harsh world
um yeah we also had a short talk about
that in the beginning
of the video
um yes
um so
first question is can he actually Force
his way through and answer his no so you
have to be on your toes you have to
climb sneak around hide in Shadows from
time to time you can take down an easy
opponent you can trick them
um
and you are a very observant creature so
you can if you watch carefully if you
take your chances if you hide and watch
people you can manipulate them and
you're quite
yeah quite a crafty and and clever
little person all right yes so you're a
great swimmer as I said before you're
good Waterman good Woodsman so we can
all use the skills that Golem has
um
so I really enjoyed that
um all these little things you did so
I'm I was a Avid Reader or am still from
time to time still reading the books um
and um so also but but especially I'm so
happy that you know you guys didn't
alter too much
of um or maybe or even nothing of of the
of the story itself and well yeah from
time to time I mean this is this is uh
video game so of course we had to uh do
things a bit different
um since it's a game but all in all we
were quite uh
we we strongly believe in in Professor
turkin's vision and we try to transport
this feeling
um but at the same time there are some
elements that we developed along the
lines that he thought and with his
little Snippets and ideas he gave us
yeah yeah yeah so uh on the Lord of the
Rings fans
um uh about to experience a really nice
um story in in this world in Middle
Earth so things will see things uh that
they have never seen before
um and that have not been told before
and also see places where things are
being built that are used in for example
the Great War so stuff like that not
telling you more um and then spoil too
much but um yeah there's uh this is not
has not been shown today but there needs
to be some other stuff revealed at some
later time for um for you to enjoy so um
this nearly brings us um to the end
of our little presentation
um now the question is
um basically
um when will the game be available and
on what platforms can you tell us I ask
you I
it's fine so I I why would it be reread
good so
um yeah um the Lord of the Rings column
will be available on May 25th
um 2023 so this year not far away and it
will be available on PlayStation 5
PlayStation 4 Xbox One Xbox series X and
S as well as PC
um a switch version will also be
available but sometime later
so um yeah 25th of May is the date where
you can play for yourselves and
stay with us follow us on our social
channels and
um a lord of the ringsgame.com so the
golemgame.com sorry and um other places
you can get all the new stuff new infos
and everything and um also
um check out the latest
um
story trailer from our partners naked so
um that's really um something if you've
missed out on that you should really see
that as well so damiri um that's it for
today
um we will surely do something like this
in some time again and um very
much better thank you very much that was
like really amazing deep dive I know
there's more and yeah I will ask for
that at some point later thanks so much
everybody and yeah have a great day good
night wherever you are and
um talk to you soon bye bye bye thank
you Cheerio Cheerio bye-bye